[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
الجوانبه
تفشن وبائي قادم وتضاعف لاعداد القتلى
سيناريوهات سوريا بعد الزلزال والسياسه
توفاقم الكارثه
هيك تحت السماء اولاد صغيره
وفي تركيا اكثر من مليونين مشرد بعد
الزلزال وقاتلوا اماكن الايواء المؤقته قد
يظلون هناك طويله
بريطانيا تحول تركيزها في مواجهه الارهاب
الى الدول المعاديه ايران والصين وروسيا
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
تحذير لاوكرانيا من استهداف القرن ليس من
روسيا بل من وزير الخارجيه الامريكي وخوف
من رد فعل بوتنه
في سوريا بعد الزلزال المدمر لا شيء صالحا
للحياه ولا احد يساعد كذلك الاستئناف
الحياه في البلد المنكوب بالحرب اصلا فشل
السياسيون في تنحيه خلافاتهم جانبا فنعكس
ذلك كازمه جديده على المتضررين بعد اسبوع
على ارسال الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه
لمساعدات الى مناطق الشمال الغربي السوري
لم تسمح فصائل المعارضه المواليه لتركيا
بدخول هذه المساعدات واليوم تعلن الاداره
الذاتيه الكرديه انها ستعيد المساعدات الى
مناطقها بعد هذه الاعاقه ولا احد متضررا
الا السوريون
وعليه وفي الوقت الذي نؤكد نحن في الاداره
الذاتيه لشمال وشرق سوريا على ان هذا
الموقف غير ان هذه المواقف غير صحيحه
وتزيد من معاناه المتضررين وتجعل معاناتهم
مصنفه تحت بنود ومواقف سياسيه
نرفضها نحن فاننا وبكل اسف وبعد مرور اكثر
من سبع ايام على اعاقه وصول دعمنا
المتضررين سنقوم بسحب المواد التي كانت
على معبر ام جلود والمجهزه لادخالها
للمناطق المتضرره
هذا جانب من الماساه جانب اخر هو داخل
المناطق المتضرره بالفعل محذر منه الاتحاد
الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر حيث يتخوف الاتحاد من تفشن خطير
للامراض في سوريا يبرر الاتحاد المنظمات
الصحيه الامر بانه اذا لم يتم توفير مساكن
دائمه لمئات الالاف من النازحين في القريب
العاجل فان التفشي الوبائي امر غير مستبعد
ياتي ذلك بينما يعيش من حالفهم الحظ من
السوريين في مدارس ايله للسقوط بعد
الزلزال الذي ضربها وذلك كحل افضل من
المخيمات
بتمنى انه بس هلا شويه تاجيل مشان المدرسه
احنا هلا باركين فيها لانه ما عندنا بيوت
يعني هلا صفينا ان احنا بس بالمدارس قلنا
يعني هلا بيوتنا نستقر فيها طاول طاوله
بدايه تهبطت يعني
عشان نرجع على البيوت اللي بده يعطونا
اياها عشان نامن الاطفال انه ترجع المدارس
هلا فحوصات شوي يعني كلها تتاجل شوي
المدارس مشان هالاطفال
من جهته قلع منسقه الامم المتحده
الاقليميه للشؤون الانسانيه للازمه
السوريه مهند هادي ان عدد القتلى في
البلاد جراء الزلزال من المرجح ان يتصاعد
مع عمل الفرق لازاله الانقاذ في المناطق
المتضرره بشده
نامل ان لا يرتفع عدد الضحايا كثيرا ولكن
مما نراه ونسمعه لا يمنحنا الدمار الذي
خلفه ذلك الزلزال في الحقيقه الكثير من
الامل في ان تكون هذه نهايه الامر قبل ان
يبدا الزلزال كان هناك حوالي اربعه ملايين
ومائه الف شخص بحاجه الى المساعده في شمال
غرب سوريا كثير منهم نازحون الان ومع
تزايد هذا العدد نجد صعوبه كبيره في تحديد
عدد الاشخاص الذين نجحوا مجددا بسبب
الزلزال لكن يمكنني ان اؤكد لكم ان الامم
المتحده وشركائها يبذلون قصار جهدهم
لتوفير الماوى المؤقت لهؤلاء الاشخاص
بالاضافه الى المساعدات الاخرى المطلوبه
اذا نتوجه مشاهدينا لنشاهد هذه الصور التي
وصلتنا منذ قليل لانقاذ امراه في كهرمان
مرعش بعد
258 ساعه تحت الانقاد طبعا هذه معجزه ان
تخرج هذه المراه حيه بعد تقريبا احد عشر
يوما على الزلزال
الكثير من الاطباء هناك اجماع على انه اي
شخص يمكنه فقط ان يعيش بين ثلاثه الى خمسه
ايام من دون طعام او ماء وفي ظل يعني
انخفاض كبير بدرجات الحراره تعانيه كل
المناطق في تركيا وسوريا ولكن ها هي معجزه
تخرج امامكم مشاهدينا لامراه لا تزال حيه
بعد كل هذه الساعات
يعني هناك نظريات وحديث من يعني اشخاص
كانوا متواجدين هناك بانه ربما الزلزال
والامطار لاحقا زودت
الاشخاص الذين كانوا تحت الانقاد بالمياه
وهو ربما اعطاهم يعني املا اكثر وجعلهم
يبقوا احياء بعد كل هذه الايام
يعني هذه الاخبار الجميله التي تاتينا من
تركيا كل يوم لا نسمعها فعليا من سوريا
للعديد من الاسباب من الجانب السوري ينضم
الينا من مدينه سلقين في ريف ادلب الصحفي
محمد الاشقر اهلا بك محمد يعني
ضعنا في اجواء المساعدات التي تصل والاواء
نعم انت حدثنا عن المساعدات فنحن نتحدث عن
جانبين الجانب الاول هو المساعدات المقدمه
من الامم المتحده والتي وصل عدد
الشاحنات التي دخلت محمله بمساعداتها
اليوم الى
128 شاحنه كان اخرها اليوم عندما دخلت 22
شاحنه محمله ببعض الخيام والسلل الاغاثيه
الغذائيه طبعا بالاضافه
لعده شاحنات اليوم دخلت 47 شاحنه تقريبا
محمله بالمواد الاغاثيه الغذائيه والغير
غذائيه مثل الخيام ومستلزماتها والملابس
وغيرها من احتياجات تفيد المتضررين من
الزلازل هذه السبعه واربعين شاحنه تم
تنسيق دخولها من قبل الجمعيات الخيريه
والمنظمات الانسانيه المحليه والدوليه
العربيه وايضا يعني هناك شاحنه محمله
بالتبرعات العينيه التي تم جمعها نتيجه
الحملات الشعبيه خارج سوريا طبعا هنا
اتحدث انا عن معبر باب الهوى الحدودي مع
تركيا في ريف ادلب اما في ريف حلب الشمالي
وتحديدا في معبر باب السلامه الحدودي
فمجموع الشاحنات التي دخلت الى حد هذه
اللحظه
84 شاحنه محمله بمختلف انواع المواد
الاغاثيه ايضا الغذائيه والغير غذائيه من
خيام وغيرها وملابس وطحين طبعا هذه ايضا
هذه الشاحنات دخلت بتنسيق من مختلف
الجمعيات الخيريه والمنظمات الانسانيه
المحليه وايضا هناك شاحنات دخلت محمله
بالمساعدات العينيه التي تم جمعها من قبل
السوريين في الخارج طبعا من معبر باب
والجميع يعلم ان هناك قرار اممي جديد يسمح
بدخول المساعدات الامميه من خلال هذا
المعبر لمده ثلاثه اشهر طبعا مجموعه
الشاحنات المحمله بالمساعدات الامميه التي
دخلت من خلال هذا المعبر معبر باب السلامه
الحدودي هو ثلاثه عشر شاحنه كان اولها قبل
يوم امس عندما دخلت عشر شاحنه واخرها يوم
امس عندما دخلت شاحنتان وكان من المفترض
ان تدخل اليوم شاحنتان ولكن لم تدخل من
معبر باب السلامه طبعا ايضا معبر حمام
يعني في ريف مدينه عفرين وهو اقرب معبر
لمدينه جنديرس المنكوبه طبعا دخلت منه
مجموعه شاحنات محمله بالمواد الاغاثيه
الانسانيه وسرعان ما توجهت الى الى
المتضررين في مدينه جنديرس وغيرها وغيرها
من المناطق في عموم مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
طبعا محمد يعني جميع هذه انا انتهى وقتي
ولكن اود ان اسالك عن نقطه باختصار لو
سمحت الصليب الاحمر اتحاد الدولي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر يتخوفون من
تفشي خطير للامراض من خلال الجولات التي
تقوم بها بين الناس بالمستشفيات هل لمستم
اي مؤشرات لمرض معين يتفشل الان لوباء
نعم يعني في الحقيقه هناك مخاوف كثيره من
انتشار الاوبئه والامراض هنا في شمال غرب
سوريا لعده اسباب لعلاء السبب الرئيسي
والاول هو احتماليه وجود يعني ضحايا تحت
الانقاض وتحلل جثثهم تحت الانقاض قد يسبب
بعض الامراض في مختلف المناطق المنكوبه
والسبب الاخر هو يعني
اقتضاض المراكز الايواء المؤقته
بالمتضررين وموجات البرد الشديده التي
يعني تضرب المنطقه خصوصا اننا هنا في
منطقه شمال غرب سوريا في منطقه شديده
البروده يعني تسجل درجات حراره منخفضه في
ساعات الليل المتاخره وهذه يعني قد تسبب
جزيلا لك محمد اعتذر عن المقاطعه ولكننا
سنذهب لنستمع الى الرئيس جو بايدن في هذا
التصريح
الصحفي
ولكن
[موسيقى]
يعني مشاهدينا في هذا التصريح الصحفي
بايدن يتحدث عن الاجسام الغامضه الطائره
التي شوهدت في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هي فعليا ثلاثه اجسام لم يتم تحديد
طبيعتها وتم اسقاطها يوم الجمعه الماضي
كان هناك تكهنات حول ان كانت لدواعي
تجسسيه ام لاغراض تجاريه تاتي هذه الحادثه
طبعا بظل التوتر بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والصين على خلفيه المنطاد
الصيني الذي حلق فولك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ثم يعني تم اسقاطه نتابع
بالزلزال اذا مشاهدينا ازمه سكن حاده
تواجهها تركيا بفعل الزلزال والسكان
المشردون في المناطق المنكوبه يتجاوزون
المليونين بحسب خبراء تركيا تتعامل مع
واحده من اسوا حالات التشرد في العالم في
اعقاب الزلزال حيث تسعى الحكومه لتوفير
الماوى لمئات الالاف من النازحين لاوائهم
لجات الحكومه فعليا الى خليط من الحلول
المؤقته بما في ذلك اقامه مخيمات ومنازل
من الحاويات في ضواحي المدن المدمره ايضا
اخلت السلطات الطلاب من مساكنهم الجامعيه
في جميع انحاء البلاد لافساح المجال
للناجحين الانتقادات لم تاتي من الطلاب
وعائلاتهم بل جاءت من المتضررين والمعارضه
السياسيه بسبب ما يصفونه باستجابه الحكومه
غير المنظمه وغير الكافيه وسط الغضب
الشعبي المتزايد اعلن الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان يوم الثلاثاء عن مجموعه من
الاجراءات منها مباني عاليه الجوده لتلبيه
احتياجات الاسكان في منطقه الزلزال
باكملها في عام واحد اردوغان قدر عدد
المنازل المنهاره او المتضرره بشده بمئتين
211 منزل بينما يتوقع خبراء ان العدد لا
يقل عن 400 الف منزل ما يجعل اكثر من
مليوني شخص دون ماوى اضافه الرئيس التركي
انه تم نصب اكثر من 175 الف خيمه في منطقه
الزلزال لايواء النازحين على ان الحكومه
تبدا ببناء 30 الف منزل جديد في اوائل شهر
مارس على الارض قال الاتحاد التركي
للمؤسسات والشركات ان الاضرار الاقتصاديه
التي سببها الزلزال قد تصل الى 84 مليار
دولار على الاقل على ان يخصص الجزء الاكبر
من المبلغ لاعاده بناء المنازل والبنيه
التحت
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مفرد العربيه عمار الهندي اهلا
بك معنا عمار يعني اطلعنا على تطورات
المشهد لديك
لتعرفنا بعد قليل ايضا على حاله يعني يمكن
وصفها بانها ايضا معجزه بالطريقه التي
انقذ بها نفسه من تحت الركام اترك الكلام
لك ولضيفك
صحيح راويه نحن معنا شاب اسمه محمد انقذ
نفسه بنفسه تحت الانقاض يعني لم يمكث
كثيرا ربما لساعات لا ادري سبع او ثمان
ساعات ولكنه استطاع ان يخرج من تحت
الانقاض وينقذ من تبقى من اسرته ووثق ذلك
بفيديوهات وانا رايتها عبر هاتفه وهذه
كانت حاله فريده على ايه حال قبل ان نتحدث
الى محمد
اعمال الانتشار الجثث والمفقودين من تحت
الانقاذ توقف توقفت الساعه السابعه مساء
وتستانف غدا صباحا وانا طبعا يعني هنالك
عائلات كثيره لا زلنا نشاهدها في هذه
المناطق تجلس الى جانب البنايات التي لا
تزال تحت الافقاد تحوي جثامين
اشخاص من اسرهم وافراد من اسرهم على ان
تخرج صباح يوم غد وهذا يعني طبعا فيه
تاخير وفيه خوف من انتشار وامراض خصوصا
وان الجثمين والجثث بدات راويه تتحلل على
ايه حال معنا محمد على الهواء وانا ساستمع
منه واستمع لاول مره لانه طلبت منه ان
يحتفظ بالتفاصيل حتى اسمعهم ما اسمعها
معكم بعد ان شاهدت الفيديوهات محمد اولا
الحمد لله على السلامه اعرف انك انت مرهق
وانا مرهق ولكن احتاج منك تروي لي ايش كيف
استطعت فعلا انك تخرج من تحت الانقاض
لوحدك كيف يعني رب العالمين طبعا اكيد اول
ما صار الزلزال يعني بس انا اهم الاولاد
انا ما همي حالي كم ولد عندك عندي ولد
وبنتين كنتوا كلكم تحت الامر بنفس الغرفه
ما كان في ضوء ابدا عم يجينا هواء بس ما
كان في ضوء ابدا يعني ما عم نعرف انه منين
هذا عم يجي صرت كمان فرجتك بالفيديو انه
عم شوف بلكي ليه نشوف نجم او ضوء قمر او
اي شيء انه مشان اطلع يعني اعرف منين احفر
واطلع وانا وين صرت يعني طابق تاني بس هلا
يعني ما في ما في بنايه اصلا
طبعا
يعني ما بعرف انه احفر وين بدي اطلع اطلع
فوق ولا أدي كنت انزل تحت الارض ما بعرف
الاتجاه مجهول يعني نعرفه المهم لحتى طلع
الضوء صرت احفر صيح انا صيح صيح صيح ما
حدا يسمعني صحن يعني بالتركي
ظليت انا تقريبا للساعه 5:30 او 6:30
ضليت تحت الانقاذ يعني وصرت وقتها صرت
احفر ضليتي في شبكه اتصال تتصل
انا تقريبا شي ثلاث ساعات لحتى طلعت ضلينا
تحت الانقاذ شي سبع ساعات اقل شيء وما كان
في ولا اي جهه مساعده ولا اي شيء ابدا طيب
انت كيف انقذت نفسك بالاول خرجت بعدين
انقذت اسرتك ولا نفس المكان لا انا اول
شيء طلعت حالي يعني انا
صاير المحل اللي قاعد فيه قريب كتير على
البرنده
وصارت شيل يعني احفروا وشيل البلاط اللي
موجود بالارض لحتى طلعت يعني انا موشي وقت
طلعت يعني طلعت من هون والمحل كتير كتير
ضيق يعني بشكل مو طبيعي ضيق والاطفال
بعدين صرت احفروا يعني احفروا شي الحجار
بايديه في سؤال انا اساله لكل شخص التقيته
من الناجين تحت الانقاب شو شعورك كان وانت
بتصرخ وبتنادي وما حدا سامعك فعليا انا
نفسي يعني بدي في الشعور من ايش حسيت بخوف
رعب حسيت انها النهايه ايش حسيت يعني اول
ما صار هاي الشغله لا في كهرباء لا حدا
شايف حدا يعني كل شيء كل شيء يعني رعب
لحاله بيكفي الخوف يعني اقل شيء يطلب
مساعده ما حدا يلبيك يعني هلا مثلا انا في
شخص على مؤاخذه في رجل بالبيت بغير بيت ما
في لا زلمه ولا شيء والنساء ما يعني
مشاهدينا بما يخص الخطاب الذي كان يلقيه
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن حول الاجسام
الغامضه الطائره بايدن يؤكد بانه لا نعلم
حتى الان بدقه ماهيه الاجسام الطائره التي
اسقطناها وبان الاستخبارات ترجح ان
الاجسام الطائره كانت تابعه لشركات او
مؤسسات بحثيه ولا مؤشرات حتى الان على
ارتباطها بالصين او اي دوله اخرى نتابع مع
انتشار مئات المخيمات المستحدثه مؤخرا
لاوائي متضارير الزلزال في تركيا بدات
الحكومه التركيه مشاريع عديده لبناء مساكن
مؤقته الزميل زيدان زنكلو رصد احد هذه
المشاريع في التقرير التالي
ضمن مسائل حكومه التركيه لتوفير مساكن
مؤقته لمتضرري الزلزال بدات هنا اعمال
تشييد 300 منزل مسبق الصنع في مدينه
اصلاحيه بولايه غاز عنتاب جنوب تركيا هذه
المنازل ستستوعب 300 عائله تقيم حاليا في
خيام قدمتها هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه افاد من المتوقع ان يتم تسليم هذه
المنازل لاصحابها في غضون 20 يوما كحد
اقصى هذا المشروع ليس الوحيد من نوعه بل
هناك مشاريع مشابهه هنا في مدينه اصلاحيه
او في بقيه المناطق المنكوبه ويعتبر هذا
المشروع احد الحلول المؤقته التي طرحتها
الحكومه التركيه كحل بديل للسكان
المتضررين من الزلزال لحين الانتهاء من
اعمال اعاده الاعمار وبناء المساكن
الجديده من مدينه اصلاحيه في ولايه غازي
عنتاب زيدان زنجلو
[موسيقى]
جرح غائر احدثه زلزال تركيا وسوريا وكان
من المتوقع ان يقرب بين الاتراك والسوريين
القاتنين في تركيا الا ان صحيفه وولد
الامريكيه اشارت الى ان هناك تصاعد بمشاعر
العدائيه بين السوريين او تجاههم في جنوب
تركيا في اعقاب الزلزال الاستياء التركي
ينطلق من اتهام بعض الاتراك للاجئين
السوريين في البلاد بسرقه المتاجر
والمنازل المتهدمه وجرى تداول شعارات على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي منها لا نريد
السوريين وايضا لم تعودوا محل ترحيب كما
انتشرت بعض عروض المساعده في الفضاء
الالكتروني التي تعرض مساعده منكوبي
الزلزال شريطه ان يكونوا سوريين او يكون
اتراك فعليا مواطنون سوريون قالوا انهم
باتوا لا ماوى لهم بسبب هذا الزلزال بعدما
طردوا من مخيمات الطوارئ وواجهوا اهانات
الى ان بعض السوريين الذين يعيشون دون
اوراق رسميه في تركيا يخشون الوصول الى
السلطات طلبا للمساعده خوفا من تعرضهم
للترحيل وتستضيف تركيا ما يقرب من اربعه
ملايين لاجئ سوري يتركز كثير منهم في جنوب
البلاد قرب الحدود السوريه ورغم ان
الاستياء من السوريين ليس امرا جديدا غير
ان الزلزال ادى الى تفاقم هذا التوتر كما
كانت التوقعات تشير الى انه ملف اللاجئين
في السوريين سيكون موضوعا رئيسيا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه هذا
العام
[موسيقى]
اذا اثار الزلزال استياء بعض الاتراك تجاه
اللاجئين السوريين في البلاد الذين يتم
تحميلهم دون دليل مسؤوليه عمليات النهب
وسط الدمار والفوضى وافاد سكان وعمال
اغاثه بوقوع عمليه نهب وتوقف عدد من فرق
الاغاثه الاجنبيه عن العمل لفتره وجيزه
بسبب تدهور الوضع الامني بينما يكافح سكان
ولايه هاتاي جنوب شرق تركيا على الحدود مع
سوريا من اجل البقاء على قيد الحياه بعد
الزلزال اصبح السكان السوريون الذين
يعيشون هناك منذ اكثر من عقد هدفا للغضب
المتزايد السكان محرومون من الماوى
والكهرباء والمياه بينما يواجه السكان
سكان المدينه المنكوبه نهبا متزايدا في
وقت تحاول فيه القوات الخاصه والجيش في
جميع انحاء الولايه منعه
[موسيقى]
خانوا اهالي انطاكيا عندما غادروا المدينه
غادروها وهم يسرقون لا اقول انهم جميعا
سيئون ولن اقول ذلك زعت العجب بك هناك الم
شديد والجميع يعاني بالفعل بغض النظر عن
هويتهم واضافه التوتر هنا وفي وسائل
الاعلام سيؤدي الى انفجار الغضب في
المجتمع وتفاقه الوضع
تتابعون معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
الحكومه اللبنانيه تعترف بسعر السوق
السوداء وتقرر تسعير السلع على اساسه
والمودعون غاضبون ويحرقون المصارف وسط
بيروت
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت شرطه مكافحه
الارهاب البريطاني انها قررت تحويل
التركيزها في مواجهه الارهاب لمواجهه
التهديدات من دول معاديه كاروسيا والصين
وايران وقال رئيس وحده مكافحه الارهاب في
لندن ماجوكس انه تم تحويل التركيز لمواجهه
محاولات دول اجنبيه لترهيب الناس والتورط
في مؤامرات قتل وخطف في بريطانيا واضاف
المسؤول البريطاني انه يجب لعب دور في
انفاذ القانون ضد دول المعاديه وهو امر
غير مسبوق مشيرا الى ان ايران نفذت ما لا
يقل عن 15 محاوله لاختطاف او حتى قتل
مواطنين بريطانيين او افراد مقيمين في
المملكه المتحده تعتبرهم طهران تهديدا
وقال المسؤول الامني البريطاني ايضا ان
الشرطه تجري تحقيقات في مزاعم بان الصين
ادارت العام الماضي مراكز شرطه في مدن
رئيسيه في العالم بما في ذلك نيويورك ونفت
الصين هذه الاتهامات
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الاقتصاد اللبناني امين سلام
ابو امين سلام ان حكومه التصريف الاعمال
قررت السماحه بتسعير السلع بالدولار
واعتماد سعر صرف العمله الاجنبيه الرائجه
في السوق اي اعتماد سعر صرف السوق السوداء
وارجع الوزير اللبناني ذلك الى عدم
امكانيه الاعتماد على سعر منصه معينه
واضاف الوزير انه لن يتم تسعير الخبز
بالدولار وانا الحكومه اتاحت مهله حتى
الاربعاء المقبل لتطبيق الاليه الجديده
لضبط الاسعار
وفي رد فعل الشارع اقدم محتاجون على احراق
مصارف لبنانيه في العاصمه بيروت المحتاجون
اكدوا انهم سينتزعون حقوقهم بايديهم مع
ياسهم من ان تؤدي اي اجراءات حكوميه الى
تحسين وضعهم وقطع المحتاجون حركه السير في
المنطقه واشعل الاطارات المطاطيه امام
فروع المصارف وذلك بسبب الارتفاع الجنوني
في سعر صرف الدولار وتهرب المصارف من دفع
الودائع للمواطنين كما تم قطع حركه السير
في مدينه صيدا وفي جنوب لبنان طبعا وفي
بلده بدنايه للبقاعيه للاسباب نفسها
[موسيقى]
عم بشرعوا سرقه مصرياتنا ما رح نقبل هذا
تحرك بسيط قدام اللي بده يصير نحن بطل
فارقه معنا نحنا مصرياتنا بتعادل ارواحنا
الغلا اللي
الدولار ب 80 وب 85 الف وبعد ما بتعرف
لوين رايح
حطونا بمطرح نقدر نكون عنا رؤيه نحن
واياكم بالنهار ما في شيء بتسكر البنوته
نهار عم يشتغلوا باموالنا من اموالنا ونحن
اموالنا
ما فينا نشتري ربطه خبز باموالنا هالي
حراميه مجرمين
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيليه عن تقديم
ضمانات قروض بقيمه تصل الى 200 مليون
دولار لدعم مشاريع رعايه صحيه وبنيه تحتيه
في اوكرانيا كوهن اعلن ايضا بعد اجتماعه
بنظيره الاوكراني ديميتروكوليبا عن تقديم
اسرائيل لاوكرانيا المساعده في تطوير نظام
انذار مبكر ذكي
من جهتي اتهم وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ديميتروكوليبا ايران بدعم روسيا بالمسيرات
التي تستخدم لقتل الشعب الاوكراني على حد
قوله وخلال لقاء مع وسائل اعلام عربيه
اوضح كلي بان التعامل او عبريه فعليا
التعاون مع اسرائيل او عربيه ياتي في اطار
مواجهه التحدي الامنيه المشترك وهو ايران
الوضع تغير بشكل الماساوي ولدينا تحد امني
مشترك مع اسرائيل وهو ايران ولذلك يمكن
ادراك لماذا نتعاون معها الان ايران تدعم
روسيا بشكل واضح وتدعمها بالمسيرات التي
تستخدم ضد الشعب الاوكراني ولذلك نعتقد ان
هناك مجالا للتعزيز العلاقات مع اسرائيل
ومعنى منك فيوريسات مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اهلا بك معنا الليله سيد يوري
يعني كان هناك حديث لانطون بلينكن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي تحدث فيه عن عدم دعم
بلاده
لمعركه او هجوم في القرن التبرير السياسي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو عدم
استفزاز روسيا وبالتالي مخاوف من رد فعلها
على اوكرانيا ما الذي يجعلكم تتمسكون
بمهاجمه القرم وهل ستمضون بهذا الطرح حتى
دون موافقه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والناتو الداعمين العسكريين لكما
انا لست متاكدا اذا ما كنتم قد
استمعتم الى تصريح الذي ادلى به سيد
بلينكن في حقيقه الامر ان
ان القرن كان قد تم ضمه من قبل القوات
الروسيه في عام
وعدم شرعيه هذا الاحتلال قد تم اقراره من
قبل الامم المتحده وكافه الدول المتحضره
في انحاء العالم فهذه المره الاولى التي
اسمع
تفسير من هذا القبيل من الولايات المتحده
الكل يدركوا بان شبه جزيره القرم هي جزء
لا يتجزا من اوكرانيا وان اوكرانيا لا بد
لها من الحفاظ على سيادتها وسلامه اراضيها
وكافه جزء منها بما في ذلك القرم
نعم ولكن
الحديث الذي قلته لك بانه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا تدعم مواجهه القرم
هو كان لتصريح لم ينشر لي بلنكن في لقاء
جمعه بعده قاده
لن اتكهن حول هذه التصريحات لانه علنا
الولايات المتحده قد قالت من قبل بان
الامر متروكا تماما لاوكرانيا الدوله ذات
السياده لتقرر الوقت والوسيله بالطريقه
التي سوف تقوم بها باستعاده اراضيها
الموقف الرسمي للاسره الدوليه هي ان شبه
جزيره القرم جزء لا يتجزا من اوكرانيا وان
مساله الخوف من اي استفزازات هذا ما هذا
ما يثيره غضب الاسره الدوليه الاسره
الدوليه يجب ان لا تخاف او تخشى من اي
هجوما من هذا القبيل لكننا اظهرنا في كل
مره باننا نحن في ميدان المعركه نقوم
بالحاق الهزيمه بالجيش الروسي
والذي لا يحقق اي نجاح حتى اللحظه وفي نفس
الوقت ايضا
نتفهم بصوره مؤكده بان الرساله التي نبعث
بها الى القاده الدولي بان نتبعات سوف
تكون كارثيه اذا ما تركنا القرن اسيره بيد
الروس وهذا التصريح قد لا يكون هو تصريحا
مسؤولا من قبل مسؤولين في الولايات
المتحده الى جانب المخاوف السياسيه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه هناك حقائق
ومخاوف اعلنها الناتو منذ يومين عن نقد
نقص بالذخيره لديه لانه استعمال الذخيره
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه هو اكثر بكثير
من وتيره الانتاج وتيره انتاج الاسلحه هل
برايكم
سيحرك فعليا
وتيره انتاجه للاسلحه
ويزودكم بكل ما تطلبونه
وقتها يعني ندخل باطار ما يسمى باقتصاد
الحرب
انت محقه في اثاره هذا الموضوع فهو امر
مهم فهذه حرب غير مسبوقه على
مستواها فهي اكثر حرب
مستعره نعيشها منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه لعلكم تتذكرون خلال فتره الصيف
كان هناك بعض الايام عندما
تقوم القوات الروسيه على سبيل المثال
باستخدام اكثر من 50 الف قذيفه مدفعيه
وكانت اوكرانيا ترد عليها بالمثل علينا ان
نتفهم بان هناك
نسبه كبيره
لاستهلاك هذه الذخيره ويوم الامس فقط
على خلفيه اجتماعي وزراء الدفاع الذين
كانوا حاضرين من مجموعه من دول الاوروبيه
وبعضها
تقالوا بان عمليه الدفاع في اوروبا سوف
تقوم الان بالاسراع وسوف تقوم بانتاج
المزيد من الذخيره لان الجميع يتفهم ان
المخاطر سوف تبقى موجوده
ولا بد لاوكرانيا ان تحقق النصر لذا لابد
من تزويد هذه الاعداد المطلوبه لاوكرانيا
بما في ذلك الدبابات والطائرات المقاتله
وانظمه الدفاع الجوي وغيرها جزيلا لك
منساك مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
حاكم مدينه تيفاستوبول في شبه جزيره القرم
ان روسيا اسقطت الطائرات المسيره اوكرانيه
حاولت شناه هجوم على عاصمه
المدينه ان طائرتين بدون طيار اسقطتا او
اسقطتا فوق البحر وان القوات الدفاعيه
صدرت الهجوم مشيرا الى كل شيء اصبح هادئا
في المدينه
هي اكبر مدينه في شبه جزيره القرم وهي
موقع استراتيجي يكتسب اهميه كبيره حيث تعد
قاعده لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي في
يناير اكد الرئيس الاوكراني
باستعاده شبه جزيره القرم التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا وقال للمنتدى الاقتصادي
العالمي في دافوس انها ارضنا اراضينا لكن
رغم اصرار اوكرانيا على مهاجمه شبه جزيره
القرم يقف في الدعم الاكبر لها في الحرب
مترددا نتحدث عن الولايات المتحده في
اتصال هاتفي لم يتم بثه بين وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن ومجموعه من
الخبراء يوم امس قال رئيس الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه ان اي محاوله لاستعاده شبه
جزيره القرم ستكون خطا احمر بالنسبه
الامر الذي ينذر باستجابه روسيه اوسع حسب
بوليتيكو فان تصريح بلينكن كان ردا على
سؤال حول امكانيه امريكا لاوكرانيا من اجل
تحقيق هدفها الطويل الاجل وهو استعاده
الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها روسيا لم يتوقف
عند هذا الحد بل قال ان الولايات المتحده
لا تشجع اوكرانيا على استعاده شبه جزيره
القرم لكن القرار يرجع الى
يؤكد ان التركيز الامريكي الان ايضا هو
يهدف لمساعده اوكرانيا على ان التقدم في
المناطق التي يتركز فيها القتال كشرق مثلا
[موسيقى]
لم يبتعد بلينك كثيرا عما قاله مسؤولون
كبار في البنتاجون لاعضاء لجنه القوات
المسلحه في مجلس النواب قبل اسبوعين حيث
اكدوا انهم لا يعتقدون ان اوكرانيا يمكن
ان تستعيد شبه جزيره القرم في المستقبل
القريب ويعتبر الامريكيون ان امرا كهذا قد
يستفز ردا من بوتين الذي يرى ان شبه جزيره
القرم هي جزء من روسيا وان الاوكرانيين
استفادوا من خطا الاتحاد السوفيتي حيث نقل
الاتحاد السوفيتي اداره القرم الى جمهوريه
اوكرانيا التابعه له عام 1954 ثم مع
استقلال اوكرانيا عام 1991 استقلت القرن
كجزء من اوكرانيا وهو ما يراه بوتين خطا
يتم تصحيحه مع ضم القرم عام 2014 حتى اكثر
الامريكيين تفاؤلا بشان مستقبل القرم رئيس
الاركان مارت ميلي قال ان استعاده
اوكرانيا للقرن يمكن ان يحدث ولكنه صعب
للغايه
المهمه العسكريه الخاصه بطرد الروسي من كل
اوكرانيا صعبه جدا ولن تحدث خلال اسبوعين
الا اذا انهار الجيش الروسي باكمله وهو
امر مستمد لذا من باب الاحتمالات احتماله
ان يحقق الجيش الاوكراني النصر الكامل
بمعنى طرد الروس من كل اوكرانيا بما في
ذلك شبه جزيره القرم احتماليه حدوث ذلك
عسكريا في اي وقت قريب هي احتماليه بعيده
ضخمه مليئه بالدفاعات الجويه ومخازن
الذخيره والعشرات الالاف من القوات توجد
مئات الخنادق والمواقع المحصنه التي تمتد
الى مئات الكيلومترات يقول خبراء امريكيون
ليبوليتيكو انه من الصعب على القوات
الاوكرانيه اختراق هذه الخطوط الروسيه حتى
مع استمرار الدعم العسكري السخي من الغرب
ثم ان امريكا ايضا لم تسلم اوكرانيا اسلحه
تمكنها من مهاجمه القرن فمثلا تطالب
اوكرانيا بصواريخ اتاتمس التي يصل مداها
الى 300 كيلومتر ليبلغ او يبلغ مسؤولون في
البانتاجون ممثليكي بانه لا يوجد لدى
الولايات المتحده فائض من هذه الانظمه
الصاروخيه التكتيكيه حتى تزود اوكرانيا
بها وهو رد يجنب امريكا ربما حرج اعلان
تخوفها من رد الفعل الروسي على خطوه كهذه
[موسيقى]
بعد مئه وواحد و 11 عاما تحديدا في اعماق
الاطلانتي صور نادره لتايتنك تظهر لاول
مره بعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ان امريكا ستسقط اي جسم طائر يمثل
تهديدا لها وقالب ايضا انه لن يعتذر للصين
على اسقاط منقاضها مشيرا الى انه سيواصل
التنافس مع الصين وحول الاجسام الغريبه
الاخرى التي تم رصدها في المجال الجوي
الامريكي قال بايدن ان بلاده لا تعرف
بالضبط ما هي هذه الاجسام الا ان
الاستخبارات ترجح انها كانت تابعه لشركات
خاصه او مؤسسات بحثيه
استقبال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لواقعه
المنطاد الصيني والاجسام الغريبه فيما بعد
لم يكن هينا موجه من السخريه على يوتيوب
وفيسبوك وتويتر وفي الوقت ذاته لا تخلو من
اسقاطات على رموز سياسيه امريكيه الى جانب
افلام هوليود
اسقاط البالون الصيني لم يكن قباله سواحل
كارولينا الشماليه وانما انتهى به الامر
على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي لا مكانا
للحديث الجاد عن المنطاد الصيني جمهور
يوتيوب وتويتر وفيسبوك لا يرحم
[موسيقى]
والماده الفلميه المجسده لاساطير سلاح
الجو الامريكي اصبحت ماده ساخره
حتى المهمات الصعبه في افلام هوليود لا
تخلو من البالون الصيني
[موسيقى]
ومن عالم هوليود الى عالم السياسه متخذ
قرار الاسقاط اطاح بهم البالون الصيني على
مدرج الطائره
ولحظه اسقاط من السماء اثاره اندهاش هيلر
كلينتون وزوجها
[موسيقى]
ولكن ما سيكون رد ترامب على الصين لو كان
في موقع الرئيس
[موسيقى]
البرامج الساخره هي الاخرى لم تترك صراع
امريكا والصين واجرت حوارا بين الطائرات
الحربيه والبندوره
في كل تغريده سخريه وكتابه التعليقات على
الفيسبوك تتوالى على الفيديوهات الساخره
في عالم موازن يخفف من وطاه الحماس الزائد
للصرع السياسي
في السياق المتصلا قال وزير الدفاع
الياباني السابق والعضو في الحزب الحاكم
اتسونوري انوديرا ان المناطيل الصينيه
ستكون سببا لاقامه علاقات وتبادل
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه مع تايوان واضاف
المسؤول الياباني ان طريقه واحده يمكن
لليابان من خلالها المشاركه مشاركه
المعلومات مع تايوان وذلك عبر الولايات
المتحده ياتي ذلك بعدما اعلنت الدفاع
اليابانيه في بيان انها تفترض بقوه ان
مناطيد استطلاع مسيره واجساما طائره صينيه
رصدت في السابق في مجالها الجوي
سوره اليوم مشاهدينا هي لطفل السوري من
مدينه جنديرس شمال غرب سوريا التي كانت
الاكثر تضررا بزلزل يسير الطفل الذي نجا
من الزلزال حاملا القليله من الخبز في
شوارع المدينه المحطمه في محاوله لاستعاده
الحياه الطبيعيه تصريح اليوم هو للرئيس
بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو الذي قال ان
بلاده ستنضم الى الهجوم الروسي على
اوكرانيا ولكن فيها حاله واحده اذا تعرضت
بلاده لهجوم وقال لوكاشينكو انه مستعد
للقتال مع الروس اذا دخل جنديون اوكرانيون
واحد الى بلاده حاملا السلاح لقتل
البلاروسين
حول عدوان محتمل ضد بيلاروسيا الامر لا
يتعلق فقط باوكرانيا بل ينطبق ايضا على
جيراننا من بلدان مختلفه فاذا ارتكبوا اي
اعتداءات ضد بيلاروسيا سنرد عليهم بكل
قسوه وستاخذ الحرب طابعا مختلفا تماما هذه
المره
ادعوا
اليوم فينا التي
لفي اول رحله لها هو لحطام السفينه
المحيط الاطلسي حيث تم نشر تسجيل مصور
نادر لم يعرض من قبل للسفينه وتظهر الصور
الحطامى المستقره على عمق اكثر من 3500 في
المحيط وتم التقاط الفيديو عام
1986 لكن لم يتم الكشف عن المشاهد الا
اليوم
[موسيقى]
مشاهده الصوره التي تحدثنا عنها للطفل من
مدينه جنديرس السوريه التي كما ذكرنا هي
اكثر المناطق او المدن التضررا بالزلزال
ونشاهد هذا الصور يحمل خبزا في شوارع
المدينه المحطمه من حوله على الحياه
الطبيعيه تعود اليها
تعتدي الساعه من العربيه لكن اخبار الساعه
لا تنتهي